alright here's a special message for me
a lot of people have been trying to find
the next Wonder Woman I found her her
name's Gina Carano
I really might get in the car I don't
think so
she is our nation's most valuable weapon
you got a car
haywire starved gina carano you and
McGregor Micheal Douglas Antonio
Banderas Channing Tatum Michael
Fassbender Bill Paxton just an endless
array of huge stars it's directed by
Steven Soderbergh who's one of my
favorite directors and this is a really
good opportunity for Gina Carano she's
an MMA fighter this is a film that can
really help display your talents in
regards to stunt work she's basically
like a female Jason Bourne and her
agency that she works for tries to kill
her when she wants to leave as you may
realize they were unsuccessful and she
decides to go and find the people
involved with trying to kill her and
work things out basically I have an
assignment most like a paid holiday
diplomatic plates
he's an emergency slap tomorrow you want
me to be eye candy you guys have been
like the perfect couple you know you've
seen plots like this before one person
was betrayed now they're gonna go after
whoever betrayed them and kill them and
it's just gonna be awesome but we
haven't seen a plot like this with the
execution this film has you never see
fight scenes portrayed like this the
fight scenes in this film are portrayed
extremely voyeuristically as if you are
in the room watching them the fights
aren't Hollywood eyes no shake and to be
found and rarely ever is there music
along with the action scenes so it
really looks as if you are watching
someone who is doing these real things
and the fight scenes are just the best
fight scenes I've seen in a very long
time they're fantastic
is the divorce final
I loved haywire I'm gonna be honest with
you and I'm not exaggerating in any way
if this film came out in December or any
time last year it would have been in my
top 15 films of the year I'm judging
this film based on what it is it's an
action movie is it the same as other
action films or does it show me
something different yes it shows me so
many things that are different the
framing and the lighting in this movie
is so excellent Soderbergh is such a
good director when it comes to that the
way the story is told even is different
it was nonlinear it really held your
attention if you wanted to follow the
plot you had to pay attention in this
movie it wasn't just a standard okay
who's gonna fight who in the next scene
it was very well told the Barcelona deal
went down I fix it you can tell me right
now while you sold me out or you can
tell me when I have my hands around your
throat Gina Carano is excellent in this
movie her performance isn't requiring
some oscar-worthy dramatic turn of any
kind she just had to be strong realistic
and had to really kick butt and do her
own stunts and she did that so well this
is one of the strongest female roles
I've seen in a long time
and she can have my babies - that's just
an addition to her awesomeness Michael
Fassbender now this is the fifth movie
in a row I've seen from him that's good
this guy's on fire I'm telling you
Michael Fassbender man Michael Foxman
we should be in her father's living room
telling him that his daughter killed a
man in cold blood this movie was just so
different it showed you a really
different way of how you looked at
things it was very old-school style I
personally feel this is sort of works
best film since Ocean's eleven it has
the same composure as the Ocean's eleven
films David Holmes very similar style of
music it's very hip it's very jazzy it's
very fun to sum a while of this movie
action films nowadays are so lazy they
don't work at the choreography they just
they shake the camera Lee fast and hope
that the audience is entertained they
don't have a strong story backing the
the fights or the action or the chases
or whatever it is she's a public threat
what did you do I did what I was
contracted to do but isn't there someone
you should be calling to bring help this
film has that and it has actors who are
willing to do their own stunts in the
film as well which is very impressive
all in all this is one of my favourite
action movies I've seen recently I can't
wait to pick up the blu-ray a director
like that and a cast like that there
must be something good here and haywire
is excellent I loved I'm gonna give
haywire in a
haywire you better run I'd like to know
what's your favorite Steven Soderbergh
movie mine personally is the very first
Ocean's eleven comment below I would
really like to know if you like this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuff my guys